foreign
[Music]
the other day right made me laugh couple
gems couple boring ones yeah as always
yeah right fam so the title of thread is
what's something you've silently said
during
tweeted me unless you saw this one too
well that's right
first thing maybe one kid won't hurt
um fan bro
same every man has been there you're in
there and it's wet and warm maybe just
one won't hurt yeah one what's one kid
what's one like obviously this is before
not once the post knot hits you like oh
my God
my bareback brain is the same as my like
exhausted brain yeah like when I'm
training legs and homeboys saying four
more reps yeah and I'm like this is
pointless I didn't I have no I don't
care anymore yeah yeah like I don't want
to be here
flip that yeah that's my when I'm four
strokes out yeah that's my like I don't
care I don't care yeah give me you give
me Clement I don't care I'm leaving it
in it feels too good yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah every ounce of my DNA is saying
leave it here yeah I can't fight that
this is genetics right it's mad when it
first comes out you're like oh yeah next
one her wigs lifting lifted
I can't see stuff like that I can't see
a lifting wig oh my damn lifting weight
yeah yeah when you see the tracks and
the weave Ah that's yeah nah yeah no no
no I'm not I'm not dealing with stuff
like that
um
this is stupid this is delay tactic is
two to the third power six away
mid stroke he's trying not to not bro
his train is hard as not tonight wow to
the third power six oh
hilarious hilarious that's hilarious I
need LeBron to drop 40 tonight
Farm where are you these men are locked
in they're trying not to knock because
they're tall is pulsing oh yeah they're
locked in the tool is Paul Satan in
there bro some lemon pepper wings would
slap right now that's not even delayed I
don't want to be I'm not trying to be
here yeah oh wow I've had times to be
fair that could be a delay tactic
because sometimes I play roles in my
head okay during the deed especially if
we're in a reverse cow okay I'm as a
delay oh if I'm pretending I don't care
about this okay that's my I don't think
about like grandmas and stuff like that
okay I think about like
boring even though it's not foreign
up here yeah I put in like a act to
myself and I'm like this is cute she
thinks you can actually do a thing so
much yeah that's what obviously neck
down I'm shaking hyperventilated
had to be reversed out I can't see the
face yeah tuna Bob I'm just like this is
light yeah this is light bro like
why not yeah lemon pepper wings yeah
they might be all right still that's
calm but yeah because if I focus on
these cheeks yeah yeah gone
settled yeah
um hilarious
this is why this motherfucker's got kids
yeah I mean ejaculating James I mean
Jacqueline no it is
oh my God so he grips the sheet when she
says that
oh facts bro sometimes I felt like I'm
gonna peel a nail off the way of gripsy
sheets bro I can't yeah she's wrapped
around you and you're gripping you're in
there oh I'm gonna break a knuckle in
there
Jesus
it's actually crazy this is so funny oh
this one yeah he's not gonna hear from
me after this
I'm terrified if that's ever been
anyone's silent thought
do you do you actually think that's ever
been a silent thought
um maybe on a quick round
okay has there ever been a chick that
you've had just not necessarily a
one-night stand with because they're
different because that's more because I
don't I don't expect to hear from you
exactly from exactly but maybe you've
done a thing you're like oh this is Yum
but you've never heard from her again
this was yum yeah you thought this was
and you want to run it back but she's
Abby says no it just doesn't even pan
out oh good question
I think so you know I'll tell you who it
was
but this one makes sense because she was
collecting heads
um was flipping
what's her name
the Coventry talked I can't remember her
name for the life of me um this thing
that one
after that one yeah
that I gave her a round and no one can
tell me
that's in a day I gave her a round yeah
yeah yeah and I never heard from her
again
but that one I didn't beat myself up
about it because I'm like I know you
just clapped next man every day that's
your agenda that's what you're known for
I don't know a guy who's banned you
twice so yeah [__] yeah wow wow it's Fox
I don't know a guy who's banged you
twice so I remember the next time I saw
her she was moving to you birthday yeah
yeah
I remember bro she came up to me all
sexy she grabbed my collar she's like I
can't remember what she said but she it
was obviously advancing and then she was
like
uh me and you to know something's like
but you moved to my boy the other day I
remember I was there
and she's like who do you mean Bird
shirt and she tried to deny it the whole
thing
yeah I'm never gonna hear the end of it
for context he was wearing a short
sleeve shirt that had Birds on it sure
yeah
um yeah wow I forgot that nickname I
want to punch her when she said that
Bird shirt do you mean
bro you you literally linked him last
week she tried to deny man yeah she
tried to deny the homeless that's that's
harsh yeah she tries to deny the halt I
couldn't believe it bro yeah to be fair
she denied another one of our boys to me
one of our boys I think I know who he is
the tall one
yeah yeah so she tried to deny me no him
to me okay and then he told me like two
weeks later it was like oh you clapped
what's her face in it and I was like how
did you know yeah and he was like she
told me and I was like cool and then
there's like a three second voice he
said while I was inside her
wow how dare you say that to me bro how
dare you say that to me that's yeah
that's what I'm called for I banged your
boy last week now what are we doing here
why are you saying this to me doing here
yeah bro I'm trying to focus yeah I'm
trying to focus um it was wild so yeah
um ah yeah she um yeah
yeah so I I never heard from her again
yeah yeah and then she denied me to my
best friend yeah so that's calm but no
that's the only time I thought I
actually did a number and like just I
didn't try to pursue her also
um so I don't know if I would have
messaged her she would have been down
but no that's the first time and only
time to my knowledge that I think I did
a good job yeah I didn't didn't hear
from that person again the there's been
plenty of not okay not plenty of times
okay there's been other times yeah one
that will always stick in my head where
I've done a terrible job yeah haven't
been man enough to admit it and I've
never heard from that person again
um
I'm trying to things happen to me a
terrible job
not man enough to admit it I never heard
from her again
I don't know because I I don't think
there's ever been a time where my first
time was terrible oh because you said
you put in words yeah yeah nah
I've had like
one
I think I've only had one terrible time
and the girl actually ghosted me to be
fair
um
and that's I think it is the only time
because that's the one that always
sticks in my head
that wet wet yeah yeah that's slip and
slide yeah right that neck breaker yeah
yeah
bro yeah she sat on it and literally
four seconds later you're gone yeah
yeah we went to sleep
she didn't say a word
he's heard her breath fam I left the
next day gave her a kiss on the cheek I
was mortified was never man enough to be
like that was awful let's run it back
Wasn't Man Enough and uh literally never
heard from her again so she moved
country or something yes she did yeah
about a year later she moved to like
I can't remember like New Zealand or
something right
um
damn that was brutal damn bro that was
brutal that was like 11 12 years ago and
it's still fresh in my mind like it was
yesterday yeah brutal tell a lie there
was a time this was on my Tinder days I
think this was in Manny
um I can't remember her name I we were
talking talking I actually didn't think
we were gonna bang that night
um but I got to it's one of those ones
where when you're talking and like
you're seeing pictures and stuff you're
thinking oh yes all that all this and
then I got there and I just wasn't
feeling her but it wasn't it wasn't her
fault it wasn't my fault I just wasn't
feeling that yeah Dynamic wasn't really
what I was imagining or thinking fam got
there we started Ellipsis I just
couldn't even wow no blood I just
literally no blood yikes family
it's coming back to me now it's coming
back to me
it's the biggest thing that she was like
she said she's like don't worry about it
I went I went to like put on my gums I
went to um I went to the bathroom
whatever came back and she was like bye
mothers no no no no not on the bed sat
on the bed
I was stood up just about to get my [__]
and bounce here she was like bye not get
up not my fam I went see yourself out I
want to see yourself outing no she was
like bye no I said right
I said right in blood today that's what
I would have told myself we're finding
blood it was it was too far ago I
couldn't I couldn't bring it back and
you just said bye left I don't even know
if I said bye I I couldn't buy I would
have speechless bye that would have
broken me down if you had it would have
broken me down left bro
I would have punched the elevator on the
way down I was living with myself I was
looking obviously all elevators have
mirrors I was looking at myself
like food is this you
is this what it's come to yeah oh no bro
bye and that was it no no no no no no no
no no no because I'd never obviously
never [__] up before I didn't actually
didn't even end up [__] herself yeah
terrible terrible oh that's [__] oh
that's really not funny it's hilarious
but it's hilarious but it's one of the
like it's never going to be an issue for
women because all women not necessarily
all women have to do is get wet but you
never need to get hard yeah fam there's
no psychology yeah the reason to
participate yeah for them to nut it's
all psychology but them to just show up
they just have to show up they just have
to be there yeah
um mandam have to not only have to rock
up they have to last yeah it's stressful
sometimes yeah yes it's all here it's
really stressful sometimes bye no yeah
no no no no no no no sat on the bed
looked at me said bye
what's that say let's charge it I have
to charge it because she had every right
bro I was in the wrong yeah I was in the
wrong I didn't charge it I had to charge
it bro straight to the game Happy bro
wow I went straight back home put it on
the gametes
wow yeah Mom yeah sorry G I don't think
I've ever had that that's Savage yeah I
don't think I've ever had that um wow
wow wow wow wow yeah but I've had a
couple couple early
yeah a couple early finishes and it's
yeah that that one where she goes to me
that was a charge that was a charge and
I I'm not I was never man enough like
you to just move on yeah
I suffered with it for months oh damn
for months oh bro it was my thing was
here yeah yeah but it was here it might
have to take it for days I remember
there was one time actually oh my Lord
there was one time bro
humiliation oh tell me there was one
time so I was seeing a thing the crazy
the crazy craze yeah
we're seeing each other and we used to
bang
and then everything was live and then
one time we basically like split up for
a little bit
hadn't seen her for a while we must have
rekindled
and the first round back yeah your boy
oh so yeah he I'm talking like 30
seconds damn 60 seconds maybe and now in
my head I'm like she knows what your
boy's about yeah yeah yeah yeah this is
minor yeah you were comfortable yeah
yeah it's just calm like don't be Vex
run it back yeah we'll run it back later
or tomorrow whatever it's minor fam we
laid in bed and she was like
I think this is a sign
I said what I like it I was half asleep
at this point she was like yeah yeah I
took it out of me and she was like I
think this might be a sign and I was
like a sign of what yeah and she was
like a sign that we just shouldn't do
this and I was like
babe what are you talking about yeah I
know what do you mean babe what are you
actually talking it was like because
like I don't know like when we were in
that moment yeah you were performing and
now we're not in that moment and you
know yeah
yeah like you know what that was yeah
no I couldn't breathe use your words you
know use your [__] words bro
I physically yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
and the fact was is that like
I was so terrorized yeah about what
she's saying yeah is that we couldn't
get blood
because it's all in here bro and the
thing is I knew I knew what she wanted
that moment was to me to grab the draw
and be like so I swear
yeah yeah you can do it yeah I was there
with the sheet covering my nipples like
babe no no babe no that's not true and
she's sitting there like prove it then
and I'm like oh God God help me Zeus bro
someone do something yeah do something
make anything happen oh an earthquake
sign bro I need I need to start and
swallow me that's tough bro bro and back
then I was too young to really verbalize
like this is what needs to happen or
like put the earnest back on her yeah
yeah yeah yeah I wouldn't I couldn't I
didn't have the the balls to be like
look
I know right now you want me to to throw
it down
but I'm a human being and I've got
feelings and you're belittling me yeah
literally yeah so literally mix it up
yeah yeah yeah encourage me be Almighty
and let's work this out there we're
gonna pattern this yeah and you're gonna
sleep like a baby but right now you're
stressing me out and I'm getting more
and more flaccid and a turtlenecking
right now I'm terrified because I don't
because I know once I leave this room
I'm not allowed back yes
so let's work this out together it's me
and you bro oh my God yeah when they
want it now they want it now
they don't care about your excuses yeah
or your lack of blood flow yeah they
can't conceptualize it yeah they
actually can't consider us it's crazy
I'm naked what do you mean you're not
horny yeah fam I'm here do something
what more do you want yeah it's all here
bro it's all in my head you can't do
this to me yeah it was it was crazy
right so real quick yeah yeah finish off
this what's something you've said
silently during sex bro random are you
prepared for Jehovah's return
bro that would
acid
wow this ain't never the pipe your baby
mama was going crazy over
no this could never be the wood she was
acting a fall over
while she's just there on top riding
yeah looking at her like raw am I not
that good enough she was moving mad and
all I was thinking was Yum Yum Yum yeah
now I'm here it can't it can't be she's
looking yeah there's been a disconnect
somewhere oh and I don't know what's
going on why it's not adding up yeah the
the Mrs gas the whole thing wow
well if you said silently during sex
another guy's name
what nothing what
God made this pipe for me
I'm not yeah
um no I already know the position we're
in yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
God made this pipe from me bro this one
man's China
might try not to announce joke so that's
hilarious he's definitely gonna make me
a mother oh this is crazy stuff he
he really thinks he's doing Sam yeah I
couldn't hear that yeah I promise you
this is why it has to be silent yeah I
couldn't hear that this is what has to
be silent I feel like Jada Pinkett Smith
I don't know what that means brother it
could mean a lot
because all it means is I know who you
feel like who do you feel like am I
August or on my will because you're best
at August
I know you're not calling me well
I feel like Jada Pinkett Smith wow that
could mean a whole lot bro my mind is
doing backflips oh wow
[Music]